jurors in the Bill Cosby sex assault
trial will resume deliberations this
morning after failing to reach a verdict
for a fifth straight day Cosby's lawyers
have repeatedly demanded a mistrial the
jurors have told the judge they were
deadlocked but the judge ordered them to
keep at it
Cosby broke his silence last night
taking time to address his supporters
when leaving the courthouse in a
Philadelphia suburb and I want to the
jury for their long days their honest
work then
I also want to thank these supporters
who've been here Cosby is accused of
drugging and molesting andrea constand
Temple University coach his attorneys
have argued that the encounter was
consensual
Cosby could face up to 30 years in
prison if convicted
for more on the cosby trial we're joined
by CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman
Ricky good morning good morning 50 hours
so far jury is back today this is longer
than Michael Jackson longer than oj how
long can it go on for it can go on for
as long as it takes as they say this
judge had a jury come back once and said
they were deadlocked he gave them an
instruction we'll talk about that in a
second
but ultimately he will not interrupt
those deliberations that until they come
back again and say they're deadlocked
they can go on and on if they come back
again and say they're deadlocked at that
point in time I think he will declare a
mistrial Ricky the order that the judge
delivered he wants the the jury to
deliver the the Spencer charge what is
that it's one of the things that defense
lawyers hate and prosecutors love when a
jury has been out for a long time and
they come in and they say that they are
hopelessly deadlocked they cannot reach
a verdict there is a charge and
instruction that we call in the lawyer
business the dynamite charge it's often
known in many other states as the Allen
charge and what it basically is telling
the jury is to go back and deliberate
and I think that the language is
instructive it says that while you
should not hesitate to re-examine your
own views and change your opinion if
you're convinced that your opinion is
erroneous do not feel compelled to
surrender your honest belief as to the
weight or effect of the evidence solely
because of the opinion of your fellow
jurors it's interesting Ricky because I
mean the Cosby's attorney is basically
saying that the jury's being asked to
compromise their views and that's why
he's calling for mr. oh well what
happens usually with the Spencer charge
of the Allen charge is that a jury gets
it and then within a couple of hours
they come back with a guilty verdict I
am
my own personal experience have never
seen a jury after a Spencer charge come
back with a not guilty verdict or they
come back hours later at dinner time or
after dinner or the following morning
and say look we really can't reach a
verdict and that's the end of the case
Mike mcmoneagle the defense lawyer for
mr. Cosby is saying judge look they say
I think they think that they can never
come back and tell you they can't reach
a verdict again that the only way that
they can come in is with a verdict and
so they're being held hostage here and
if they had a reasonable doubt as to
Andrea constants testimony on Monday
night after four hours of deliberation
their duty was to acquit because either
they believed her beyond a reasonable
doubt or they didn't our end has legal
eagle Ricki Cleveland on Judicial Watch
thanks for your time as always thank you